Announcer: Live from New York, Tonight with
Belafonte.
Harry: My relationship with Charlie, I was
not just an acquaintance.
Our survival was dependent on one another.
When you look at Charlie White, and you look
at the faces of black people, there's a serenity.
There's always a strength in his characters.
The limbs of the black subject is always powerfully
displayed.
Strong arms.
When the good fortune hit I got my own space
to command my time on television, I overdid it
with a Charlie White.
♪ I don't want no bald headed woman,
She too mean, Lord, Lordy well she too mean
♪
It shook up television because you never quite
saw anything quite like that,
all of this blackness.
I bought everything I could of his and I displayed
it and I put it on television.
I couldn't get enough of it.
Charlie White had a great champion in me.
♪ Better bow your head, Lord, Lordy, better
bow your head
Better bow your head, better bow your head
Hold that line ♪
Our dear Charles.
What are you doing now?
And wherever you are, Heaven or Hell, make
a space for me.